auparavant on lançait une bouteille à la
mer dans l'espoir que quelqu'un trouve
le message aujourd'hui c'est dame nature
qui lance un appel à l'aide un des
grands responsables
l'industrie alimentaire pourrait-on
rêver un instant d'une épicerie tu sens
plastique
peu importe où on regarde on voit
beaucoup beaucoup de place et donc la
règle c'est pas de se dire qu'on va se
tourner et pierrot plastique à
l'épicerie c'est quoi ça l'objectif
pourrait ne plus avoir de plastique mais
il faut changer vos façons normande
consommer distribués çà c'est un
changement qui est beaucoup plus
radicale bruno poussard et spécialiste
de l'emballage dans l'industrie
alimentaire
il ne faut jamais oublier que
l'emballage a sans raison d'être protégé
contenir conserver que la partie
praticité pratique le plastique mais est
ce que l'industrie en abuse
est ce que tous les aliments dans le
frais comme ça ont besoin d'une
protection aussi important que
nécessairement cet emballage on n'est
peut-être pas nécessairement le mieux
adapté pour améliorer la conservation du
produit alimentaire marque forte et le
beast et représentent les grandes
épiceries
oui ça fait plus d'emballages plus de
place et mais ça fait moins de
gaspillage alimentaire l'oeuf la poule
qu'est ce qu'on fait louise et nos
métiers et chefs de projets
scientifiques à la fondation david
suzuki
donc il ya tout un équilibre avoir
augmenté la durée de conservation des
produits pour minimiser le gaspillage
alimentaire parce que ç'a un impact
environnemental majeur au niveau des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre les
pesticides la pollution des cours d'eau
par les fertilisants par exemple mais en
même temps considéré le fait que les
emballages alimentaires vont avoir un
impact environnemental
non négligeable et majeur qui peut
perdurer beaucoup plus longtemps que la
durée de vie des produits
malgré les alertes lancées par des
environnementalistes l'industrie semble
faire le sourd de règles ya pas si
longtemps les laitues on en valais
personnes en place cycle non
effectivement
est ce qu'une volonté en ce moment en
2018 de réduire la quantité de plastique
oui beaucoup d'initiatives qui sont mis
en place entre autres les sacs de
plastique une grande réduction de
l'effet depuis dix ans pourtant quand on
regarde les chiffres il ya une
augmentation de l'utilisation du
plastique dans l'emballage en épicerie
suivent les normes du mapaq
le mapaq et l'agencé canadienne
d'inspection des aliments
deux organismes gouvernementaux qui
régissent les règles de salubrité sont
aussi pointés du doigt par le conseil de
la transformation alimentaire du québec
qui représente plus de 500 entreprises
nous on est tributaire du mapaq pour lui
ce qui est important c'est que les
aliments soient salubre puis cueillait
pote d'imposer nos aliments terre à la
fin de la course mais c'est la même
chose pour l'agencé canadienne
d'inspection des aliments quand elle
vient inspecter les aliments veut
s'assurer que le produit est paul
nicholls soit soit exempt de maladies
etc
le mapaq se défend d'exiger des
contenants en plastique
la réglementation prévoit pas de
matières spécifiques pour l'emballage
essentiellement elles doivent être
propres et d'autres ne doivent pas non
plus transmettre à l'aliment lui-même un
goût une odeur ou par exemple
contaminants chimiques
tant et aussi longtemps qu'on trouve pas
quelque chose qui va pallier à la
salubrité des aliments avec les mêmes
propriétés que nous retrouvons
actuellement en plastique et on va
utiliser du plastique
dans l'industrie alimentaire les
embouteilleurs sont les plus grands
utilisateurs de plastique en 2016
il s'est vendu 480 milliards de
bouteilles dans le monde
coca cola un des plus gros pollueurs
produits 3400 bouteille par seconde un
des ses dirigeants a accepté de nous
rencontrer
comment se sentent les gens chez coca
cola quand ils voient leurs bouteilles
dans le fond des océans avait clairement
leur logo des cris de si on est
conscient que c'est la planète là où
nous vivons donc nous ne sommes pas du
tout content de voir nos produits finis
dans les océans on peut pas annuler
entièrement le plastique bien entendu
mais on peut quand même gérer la matière
de façon à réduire les déchets qui sont
inutiles qui sont en train d'être
partout dans les océans dans les
conduits d'eau dans partout dans le
monde c'est les bouteilles de boissons
gazeuses sont consignés chez nous il
n'en est rien d autre liquide
à commencer par lots dont les ventes
juste au québec ont augmenté de plus de
50% depuis 2010 alors où on se parle
toutes ces bouteilles qui sont
recyclables à ce qu'elles sont recyclés
à 100% alors on se parle oui il n'ya pas
de ce que les jeunes et c'est
certainement pas pas encore mais l'idée
c'est d'y arriver
seulement 14% des emballages plastiques
sont actuellement recyclé sur la planète
et à voir la prolifération de nouveaux
formats et de nouveaux contenants on se
doute bien que l'appât du gain prime sur
les ambitions environnementales notre
peau du mieux sur la route gros mais si
on regarde sa bombe par en dessous du
club pour avoir moins d'humus à
l'intérieur de notre beau et ça ça
consomme plus de place est pour rien
donc si on arrêtait de vouloir berné les
consommateurs je pense que on aurait
beaucoup de gains du point de vue de
l'utilisation du plastique dans les you
go on nous dit vous êtes mes d'acheter
des grands contenants que les petits
parce que vous utilisez moins de
plastique mais les gens savent pas que
les petits contenants c'est pas
nécessairement réclame ceux du
polystyrène donc le numéro 6
donc ça c'est un défi en termes de
recyclage effectivement il devrait y
avoir des politiques encadrants qui
interdisent la mise en marché de
matières ils ne sont pas en reste là
particulièrement pour les petits volumes
mais encore faut-il savoir ce qui est
recyclable coupe presque on peut leur a
circulé contrats saas et c'est fascinant
aussi à sa propre notamment pour savoir
ce serait bien recyclage ou consignes
gaspillage ou environnement argent ou
conscience les enjeux sont énormes quand
on parle plastique pour les joueurs de
l'industrie alimentaire est ce qu'on
pourrait pas vraiment et autre chose que
le plastique qu'ils soient moins connus
est ce que c'est de réinventer le
plastique ou c'est de le traiter
efficacement de le réutiliser
si on est capable d'avoir des emballages
technique les en bout de ligne de les
réutiliser de les recycler d'avoir une
des fins de vie et les services qui met
en scène les gagnants mais les gens
travaillent là dessus
[Musique]